Let's go through an example. In the last lessons you may have noticed our
examples have been centered around social science. Like social networking, with
the cloud example and your engagement in class. But in this lesson and the next
we'll be using a lot of examples from the fields of biology and medicine. Since
statistics is heavily used in those fields as well. I drew a finch here, and
that's because this next example deals with the beak width of finches.
Specifically, scientist have looked at finches to make hypotheses about
evolution. By mapping a trait over time, like beak width. We can tell if the
environment is selecting for a particular size of beak width. Maybe there's a
particular beak size that better help this finch survive. But sometimes there
are random fluctuation in beak width due to variation in the population. Some
finches just have bigger beak widths than others. Therefore to determine
whether there is a significant change in beak width within the population over
time. We need to use statistics. If the mean beak width does significantly
increase or decrease in size. This is referred to as Directional Selection.
Then the environment allows the survival and reproduction of finches with
bigger beak widths. Let's say we know that the average beak width of all
finches is 6.07 millimeters. This includes finches that have been studied over
the last few years. But now let's say we're studying a sample of finches from
today. We want to know, do finches today have beak widths that are different in
size? That means our null hypothesis is that, the population mean for finches
today is equal to what they have been. And what should the alternative
hypothesis be? That mu is less than 6.07, greater than 6.07, or not equal to
6.07.